[موسيقى]
في عام من الوباء العالمي
، أنفقت الإمارات العربية المتحدة معظم عام 2020
في إنجاز سلسلة من الأعمال البطولية التي كان يعتقد أنها
مستحيلة ،
وربما كان الأمر الأكثر لفتًا للنظر هو أن تصبح
أول دولة عربية على الإطلاق ترسل مسبارًا
يتجول
في الكون لاستكشاف هذه الصور الأولى.
لا يزال بعيدًا عن وجهته على بعد ملايين وملايين
الأميال ، وتكدس الإمارات قدرًا هائلاً من
الثقة في تحقيق
اسمه على نحو مناسب ، فإن الأمل في الوصول إلى المريخ ليس
الهدف الرئيسي هنا ، بل يعني
هدفًا أكبر بكثير يتعلق
بمستقبل اقتصادنا.
خلق اقتصاد ما بعد النفط اقتصادًا
مبتكرًا ومبتكرًا وتنافسيًا ،
واقتصادًا مثل أي مكان آخر
على وجه الأرض
يواجه تحديًا من قبل
فيروس كورونا ،
كيف أنت جيد ، كيف حالك
عبد الله المري هو وزير الاقتصاد الإماراتي
أعتقد أن عام 2020 نعم كان يمثل تحديًا
فرصة هائلة
نتجت عن عام 2020 كانت رائعة ، شهد عام 2020
فرصًا مثل هذه التي تقع في
منطقة البركة ، وهي منطقة نائية من أبو ظبي
، أصبحت الإمارات  الدولة العربية الأولى
لتقسيم
الذرة ومن تقسيم الذرة إلى
الانقسام مع الماضي
، كانت تقوم بتحديث قوانينها على الصعيدين
الاجتماعي
والتجاري فيما بينها لتخفيف
القواعد حول شرب الكحول
للسماح للأزواج غير المتزوجين بالعيش معًا
وتقديم برنامج تأشيرة ذهبية
يمنح المغتربين أمانًا طويل الأجل
ولكن ربما الأهم من ذلك كله
السماح
بالملكية الأجنبية الكاملة للشركات ،
هل ترى أن هذه تقدم
ميزة تنافسية رئيسية لدولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة
خاصة في منطقة الخليج الأوسع هذه ،
أعتقد أنه منذ فترة طويلة
لتغيير القوانين وأعتقد
سيساعد هذا حقًا حقبة ما بعد الفحص
حيث أه أه نجذب الكثير من
المستثمرين التجاريين
، سألني شخص كيف
تصف UEE قلت إن الإمارات كانت دائمًا
ردهة فندق
حيث يأتي الجميع وهي
مفتوحة
للجميع وفي  عام 2020 ، كان لدى الإمارات العربية المتحدة شريك تجاري كبير
واحد لم يتوقعه أحد في ضربة جريئة من
الخيال الدبلوماسي
تطبيع  العلاقات مع إسرائيل ،
أول
دولة عربية تقوم بذلك منذ أكثر من 25
عامًا
، يسعدنا أن تكون الإمارات العربية المتحدة
جزءًا من الزخم
نحو الاستقرار ونمو
الإمكانات البشرية
في نهج حضاري جديد يفتح
أبواب الفرص على مصراعيها.  هل يعني ذلك
بالنسبة للاقتصاد وأعتقد أنني
أقول دائمًا
ما هو جيد للاقتصاد
جيد للناس وجيد
للمنطقة ، الإمارات العربية المتحدة تضع الصفقات
في حوالي 300 إلى 500 مليون سنويًا
كما أفهمها لدينا
نقلاً عن الوزير الإسرائيلي  رقم حوالي أربعة مليارات
عندما يتعلق
الأمر بالتجارة بين الاثنين وحوالي
خمسة عشر ألف
وظيفة وهناك تباعد هناك ،
فما هو الرقم هو عام
مغطاة يحتاج التفاعل لأخذ زخمه الكامل
هناك الكثير من أه التفويض  الذهاب
والوفد قادم وأعتقد أنه من
المهم
السماح لمساحة الأعمال بالالتقاء
أه للتفاعل وأعتقد أننا سنجد
رقمًا ربما
أه باتجاه منتصف 202  1 أعتقد أنه
في ما كان عامًا مضطربًا ، وضعت الإمارات
أيضًا العلم
أولاً عندما يتعلق الأمر بإدارة covid19 ،
وهذا يعود إلى قيادة
سياسية حساسة للعلم
والتي تتواءم مع المخاطر
بعد تسجيل الحالة الأولى في أواخر
يناير
بحلول  في نهاية المسيرة ، كان جيش صغير من
الطائرات بدون طيار في الإمارات العربية المتحدة
ينظف الشوارع
ولم يكن الأمر يتعلق فقط بقيادة تطهير في
وقت مبكر من الإمارات التي أطلقت
مراكز اختبار في جميع أنحاء
البلاد ،
فلديها الآن أحد أعلى
معدلات الاختبار للفرد
في أي مكان في العالم ،
لم يكن النهج هو كل شيء عن
جداول البيانات لشعب الإمارات العربية المتحدة القيادة
محمد بن زايد أخي العزيز ،
شكرًا لك على لطف قلبك
لمساعدة الناس وإنقاذ
الأرواح ، أرسلت الإمارات شحنات إغاثة سرية
إلى كل مكان
من  إيطاليا إلى إيران وكازاخستان كولومبيا
ومساعدة أكثر
مما تقول إنه أكثر من
مليون
بطل في الخطوط الأمامية حول العالم ،
ستكون المساعدة النهائية بالطبع لقاحًا
وكانت الإمارات العربية المتحدة لاعباً كبيراً في
مجال اللقاحات الذي
يستضيف تجربة ضخمة لشركة Cinepharm المملوكة للدولة في الصين ،
فقد كانت هذه هي المرة الأولى التي تتخذ فيها
أبو ظبي قاعدة فيما يتعلق
بالتجارب السريرية
، والآن نواصل هذا
العمل ، إنه
مهم حقًا  بالنسبة لأبو ظبي
، فهي تُظهر مثالاً على كيفية ريادة أبو ظبي
في توفير إمكانات الحلول
والقدرة على مساعدة العالم
على تجاوز هذا التخلي العالمي عن
ثلثي البصمة البشرية في العالم
خلال
رحلة طيران مدتها أربع ساعات من أبو
ظبي وهذه الجغرافيا حقًا  تعد
أبوظبي تجمع ما تسميه اتحاد
الأمل
الذي يمثل
حلاً كاملاً لسلسلة التوريد لمعالجة
تخطيط الطلب على نقل اللقاحات
، والتدريب ، والبنية التحتية للتكنولوجيا الرقمية
التي ستشهد استخدام الإمارات
لبصماتها للحصول على مئات الملايين
وربما
مليارات الجرعات من  اللقاحات
حول العالم
تمثل لغزًا لوجستيًا هائلاً ونحن
نمضي قدمًا
في العام الجديد
2021 أيهما  عندما تقوم بتدوير مكعب روبيك
يفترض المرء
أنه سيكون صعبًا ، لكن المرء يأمل أن
نرى
أننا بدأنا نرى ارتدادًا عالميًا
إلى الوراء بالنظر إلى الإمارات العربية المتحدة على وجه التحديد ،
ما هي توقعاتك لعام 2021 ، الإمارات العربية المتحدة
جاهزة للانفتاح
جاهزًا و  إن
طرح اللقاحات مؤخرًا
يعد تطورات هائلة لكل من الصحة
والاقتصاد ،
ونتوقع أن لا
يتوقع البنك المركزي في
الإمارات العربية المتحدة في الواقع
نموًا بنسبة 3.2٪ بحلول نهاية هذا
العام ، لذلك نحن
عدت وستأخذ كل ما
تصطف
عليه الإمارات للمساعدة في الوصول إلى هذه الأرقام ، وسنرى
مدى المكاسب التي ستكشفها الصفقة مع
إسرائيل عن نفسها منذ بداية عام
2021 ، وسيرتبط مسبار الأمل
بمنزله الجديد في فبراير / شباط
من المقرر أن تضيء المحطة النووية
ربع احتياجات الدولة من الكهرباء بالكامل
باستخدام طاقة خضراء نظيفة عندما تبدأ
عملياتها التجارية
في وقت مبكر من العام ، وسيفتتح معرض دبي الذي تم
تأجيله في عام 2020
أعماله أخيرًا.  oors to the world in October
إذا كان لديك رسالة واحدة
للمجتمع الدولي
بينما ننهي هذه المقابلة من
الإمارات العربية المتحدة ، فستكون ما
هي الإمارات العربية المتحدة جاهزة ، والإمارات العربية المتحدة مناسبة
، والإمارات العربية المتحدة متنوعة بشكل جيد
نظرة متفائلة حيث تستعد الإمارات
احتفل
بعيدها الخمسين في
ديسمبر وسنكون هنا لتغطية كل شيء
بيكي أندرسون سي إن إن
أبو ظبي